c'est l'heure maintenant de notre second
débat volontairement vous le savez
décalée de l'actualité on parle ce soir
de pouvoir d'achat c'est la première
préoccupation des français
57% pensent qu'il a baissé en cinq ans
et pourtant une étude de l'institut des
politiques publiques montrent que le
niveau de vie a augmenté pour 95 % de la
population des états
c'est une satisfaction pour l'exécutif
depuis le début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron le pouvoir d'achat des
français a augmenté plus 1,6 pour cent
mais cette moyenne masque de fortes
disparités
c'est ce qu'a relevé cet économiste il
s'est penché sur les prestations
sociales et les impôts décidée durant
les cinq dernières années on voit des
hausses de niveau de vie pour toutes les
catégories de revenus à l'exception des
cinq pour cent des individus les plus
modestes en fait ce qui joue
principalement en négatif c'est la
fiscalité tabac et la fiscalité
énergétique et on a du coup augmenté
durant ce quinquennat al'inverse les
ménages les plus riches semblent être
les grands gagnants du quinquennat entre
2 et 4% de pouvoir d'achat en plus
principale raison la suppression de l'
isf et la mise en place de la flat tax
un taux unique à tous les revenus du
capital dernier enseignement plus
générale les mesures de ces cinq
dernières années ont davantage
bénéficier aux français qui travaillent
on à la revalorisation de la prime
d'activité la bascule csg cotisation
sociale qui baisse certaines cotisations
sociales pour les répercuter sur as et
lorsque l'on estime c'est que les actifs
ont une hausse de +3 5% de leur niveau
de vie en moyenne ce dont s'est félicité
bruno le maire
les gagnants du quinquennat du maine
macron ce sont les françaises et les
français qui travaillent
la promesse a été tenue si le souligner
c'est peut-être parce que le pouvoir
d'achat est la priorité absolue des
français et d'après un récent sondage
80% d'entre eux pensent que leur niveau
de vie a baissé ces 12 derniers mois
qui sont les gagnants les perdants en
quelque sorte de ce quinquennat en
matière de pouvoir d'achat cette
question du niveau de vie peut-elle
prendre place centrale dans la campagne
présidentielle
voilà le thème de notre débat et je vous
présente mes invités hors laluque
bonsoir économistes députée européenne
la place publique eric delannoy
économistes également président
fondateur de cagnes et tenzing bonsoir
raphaël legendre qui est journaliste à
l'opinion bonsoir bonsoir raphaël et
puis avec nous en visioconférence
vincent drezet qui est membre du conseil
scientifique d'attac coordinateur de
l'observatoire de la justice fiscale
khattak a lancé en septembre dernier
bonsoir à vous bienvenue à vous aussi
évidemment matthieu croissandeau est
resté à mes côtés donc je le disais en
titres et en et en préambule c'est la
priorité des français en vue de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 sondages aux
hawks a publié
ce jour pouvoir d'achat 45% c'était 33 %
en 2017 c'est intéressant à la santé on
est à 30 % l'immigration 25 % viennent
ensuite la sécurité le terrorisme
l'environnement et le chômage est ce que
maintient je commence avec vous ce
chiffre de pouvoir d'achat préoccupation
principale est ce qui s'explique aussi
par l'inflation récente est assise à une
part conjoncturel d'après vous dans
cette perception je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs facteurs est le premier
facteur qui est une immense frustration
qui a été générée par la période de
confinement qui fait que à la sortie du
confinement il ya une envie de sortir
cette frustration et donc de consommer
et quand on veut consommer on se rend
compte qu'on a les moyens on n'a pas les
moyens de consommer et donc il ya tout
un ressenti autour de la capacité à se
dire quelles sont mes moyens compte tenu
du fait que les vagues et les dépenses
contraintes ont augmenté très fortement
et et compte tenu du fait qu'aujourd'hui
on a un pouvoir d'achat qui augmente et
enfin même le rapport de l'institut
politique publique on en parlera tout à
l'heure ne le nie pas après il ya des
problématiques de précision qui sont
qu'il faut pas nier mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya un ressenti comme quoi
ce n'est pas possible d'avoir eu un
pouvoir d'achat parce que moi je me sens
pas concerné alors que factuellement les
chiffres de l'insee ils sont pas ils ont
pas été truquées donc maintenant il faut
comprendre pourquoi quels sont les
mécanismes de ce ressenti et les
mécanismes de ce ressenti c'est cette
notion de reste à vivre un lit à ses
dépends contraintes notamment pour les
foyers les plus pauvres puisque on se
rend compte que si on ne parle que du
logement le logement est passé de même
pas 15% d'eads est revenue dans les
années 80 à plus de 30% des revenus dans
les foyers les 20% des foyers les plus
pauvres donc on se rend compte qu
effectivement dans la mesure où ses
dépens de contraintes augmentent on a un
reste à vivre qui est l'ennemi qui
diminue mais en même temps contrairement
à ce qu'on veut bien pensée on vit mieux
globalement simplement on n'a pas le
sentiment que c'est vrai qu'il ya cette
différence entre les chiffres et
statistiques et paul santy aurore
laluque ya le ressenti et il ya la
réalité et les chiffres ne mentent pas
sur le sujet c'est à dire que on a 1 14
8 % de français d'après l'insee qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
c'est-à-dire autour autour de 1000 euros
ça ce sont des faits se sont pas des
restes du ressenti et c'est un chiffre
qui est le plus haut depuis vingt ans
mais qu'il ya un vrai sujet alors c'est
vrai et ça faut le reconnaître pendant
la crise on n'a pas eu une explosion des
inégalités et tant mieux tant mieux
néanmoins on a six points 5 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi on a un taux de
pauvreté relativement élevé et dans la
cinquième suisse sixième puissance
économique mondiale je suis désolé c'est
pas normal il ya un sujet c'est bah
c'est pas possible on peut pas vivre
comme ça donc il va falloir à un moment
revenir sont les politiques qui ont été
menées jusqu'à présent et qui ne sont
pas liées qu'à la france hein ça a été
une mode mondiale qui a été de dire il
faut absolument baisser le coût du
travail baisser le coût du travail et on
voit ce que ça donne aujourd'hui et on
voit par ailleurs un mouvement aux états
unis de gens qui disent il faut
maintenant qu'on puisse gagner plus et
vive de notre travail donc en gros il ya
quand même un ras-le-bol d'un certain
modèle qui nous a été vendu et imposer
en partie et une demande d'avoir quelque
chose de normal en fait pour voir vivre
décemment de son travail raphaël
legendre
est ce que vous faites la même analyse
notamment sur le l'aggravation des
inégalités en france sur ces deux trois
dernières décennies en fait elles ont
pas bougé les inégalités en france
depuis deux ou trois décennies sans dit
pas assez on est allé non je suis pas du
tout à fait d'accord le taux de pauvreté
il a augmenté parce que c'est pas ton
arithmétique effectivement c'est à peu
près les deux tiers du salaire médian
vous augmentez salaire médian vous
augmenter le niveau 10 globale de la
société
mécaniquement sa relève le niveau de
pauvreté donc si vous voulez nos pauvres
sont de moins en moins pauvres en
quelque sorte qu'ils ne doivent rien à
la situation très difficile 2 millions
notamment d' actifs pauvres en france
c'est un vrai sujet ça je ne le cache
pas par contre les écarts de richesse en
france sont à peu près stables depuis 30
ans et ils sont inférieurs à la moyenne
des autres pays riches auquel on peut se
comparer il ya un coefficient
macroéconomie qui s'appelle le
coefficient de gini qui calcule sa base
héros c'est un pays parfaitement
égalitaire qui peut être parfaitement
égalitaire dans la pauvreté 1 vous
pouvez aussi être parfaitement
égalitaire dans la misère c'est possible
et 1 c'est parfaitement inégalitaire on
est aux alentours de 0,27 0,28 à un
petit peu baissé d'ailleurs ça
s'améliore pourquoi parce que avant
redistribution et mais comment se place
vous avez des cadres est mieux que les
autres pays riches en réalité on divise
par cinq environ par 4 par dont les
écarts de richesse entre les 10% les
plus modestes en france et les 10% les
plus riches avant redistribution
cet écart c'est un facteur de 20 à peu
près après redistribution des aides
sociales paiement des impôts par les
plus aisés on ramène sa 5 à 5,6 à peu
près donc et ça ça bouge pas beaucoup
depuis trente ans en réalité ce qui se
passe c'est par contre on a ce sentiment
quand même de perte de pouvoir d'achat
ça c'est depuis la crise de 2008 et la
crise financière parce que pendant dix
ans le pouvoir d'achat des français n'a
pas bougé il a même reculé dans la
période 2011-2013 pourquoi parce qu'on a
fortement augmenté les impôts 50
milliards 12 d'impôts ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez vu français sur
10 qui pensent que le pouvoir d'achat
s'est dégradé
macroéconomique mans ça n'est pas vrai
depuis trois ans il a même progressé
pendant la crise alors qu'on a subi la
plus grosse récession dans l'inconnu
depuis 100 ans mathieu ne juste pour
appuyer quand même ce que dit aurore
l'adulte vous avez évidemment sans doute
raison sur les chiffres on ne les
connaît pas et vous les connaissez mille
fois mieux que moi mais un discours est
un discours qu'imprime le débat public
depuis 20 30 ans ou en gros on demande
aux salaires les plus bas d'être
toujours plus bas parce qu'il faut
s'aligner sur les plus bas et précis
c'est la concurrence et c'est pas vrai
le smic a augmenté 30 pensant entre 1000
et 2000 juste
en réalité mettant le nez plus vite que
les salaires moyens j'ai alors je
réfléchis je dis dans le discours que
tenait aux salariés s'est fait un effort
c'est pas mal ces vacances ça va mieux
c'est laissez-nous reconstituer nos
marges ça c'est le discours des
employeurs des entreprises s'est jamais
le moment d augmenter et au moment
du jeu karim est complètement faux on
doit s'aligner sur les pays parce qu'il
faut faire face à la concurrence
chinoise à la concurrence autrefois des
pays de l'est soit là faut toujours
faire attention en revanche pour les
hautes rémunérations là faut s'aligner
sur l'euro parce qu'au nom d'une
prétendue concurrence mondiale faudrait
s'aligner sur les salaires américains
faudrait s'aligner sur les salaires les
plus chers on n'est pas loin quand même
en france à je sais bien qu'on aurait
très bien mais je le discours qui est
tenu c'est quand même celui là et donc
sa marque aussi les esprits alors on n'a
pas encore entendu vincent drezet dans
ce débat je vous donne la parole tout de
suite je donne un des indes et on va pas
mal s'appuyer vous vous en parliez 1 sur
ce rapport de l'institut des politiques
publiques le chiffre global qui est
donnée par ce rapport qui calcule
l'augmentation du point d'achat depuis
2010 est c'est une moyenne évidemment
c'est plus
397 euros par an en moyenne ça fait plus
1,6 pour cent vincent drezet comment
vous le recevez ce chiffre est ce que là
aussi vous le remettez en cause est ce
que vous dites il ya le chiffre est elle
ressentie quand c'est quoi votre analyse
mathématiquement ils sont en outre juste
une mini ne veut pas dire grand chose ce
qui est intéressant c'est que là on a
évoqué la question de la pauvre et c'est
vrai qu'il faut remonter jusqu'en 1996
pour retrouver un tout nouveau mode est
aussi élevé on peut dire que tout cela
est relatif plus pauvres
un peu moins qu'avant il n'empêche que
la société elle progresse claude michel
et comme le somme de 60 ans aujourd'hui
donc et si tu quand même dans la société
un chiffre donné un seul est important
et surtout ce qu'il faut remarquer il
faudrait élargir le débat et les deux
spectres bancs d'école qu'on a fait
l'intensité de la pauvreté au clair
c'est à dire la façon dont on s'éloigne
progressivement de ce seuil de 60% qui
fixait la pauvreté d'intensité pas au t1
plutôt tendance à s'accroître ça veut
dire en clair c'est que les taux relevés
spe et ça c'est un problème
y compris
derrière
demandé des preuves de santé les primes
se sont fait l'intensité la pauvreté au
togo ça c'est un travail et puis on a
encore évoqué là mais ce qui est
beaucoup joué
66 milliard chiffres c'est que l'élite
politique de ville on va dire une
trentaine d'années que les gens me
disent qu'à et social aura effectivement
plus tôt était déséquilibré c'est à dire
quand c'est plutôt porté sur ce qu'on
appelle les bases mobiles c'est-à-dire
les pme et les ménages qui ne peuvent
pas aller à l'étranger placé du fonds à
l'étranger
heureusement qu'il n'est pas que
français et ça c'est notamment incarné
en 2017 avec cette fameuse
transformation
la création d'une prime enfance tous les
signaux que été envoyés et bien reçu
mais compris notamment par le 1% sont
tellement % des français les plus riches
et là des chiffres ne trompent pas
puisque qu'ils ont objectivement
massivement bénéfices il de laisser sans
voix ce qui est relativement discours
convient et c'est vrai mathématiquement
que les inégalités entre l'idée d'en
soigner plus qu une des personnes riches
n'ont pas bougé mais dès lors ce
commentaire on affine le raisonnement
sur les plus riches c'est une autre
histoire c'est pas une question de
ressenti
même si effectivement choisi l'été sur
les dépenses contraintes les portes de
logement et de transport qui explique
notamment ont des gilets jaunes dans les
communs 2018
dans un instant vincent droz et on va
essayer d'améliorer quand même un peu la
liaison qui est pas parfaite je vais
continuer de dérouler comme ça certains
des éléments de de ce rapport de cette
étude de l'institut des politiques
publiques
ses gains de pouvoir d'achat en fonction
des revenus on retrouve ces chiffres
plus de 184 euros c'est pour un ménage
qui dispose de 1149 euros par mois alors
ça grimpe après un peu plus puissants 22
pour un ménage qui à 1537 euros par mois
+
1287 pour un ménage qui dispose de 2000
199 euros par mois et + 4 milles 462
euros pour un ménage qui dispose de onze
mille 700 euros 713 euros par mois donc
là c'est aussi effectivement sur la
durée du quinquennat perry delannoy
c'est si on rentre un peu dans le détail
c'est le pouvoir d'achat des gens qui
travaillent qui augmente le plus en
france alors il ya une chose sur lequel
le rapport est totalement cohérent par
rapport à ce qu'avait à la communication
qui avait été faite par bercy c'est
qu'effectivement de manière d'ailleurs
assez homogène pour le coup tous les
salariés qu'ils soient du secteur public
ou du secteur privé tous ceux qui ont un
travail ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat
augmenter on est aux alentours de 3 5%
d'augmentation durant le quinquennat
alors les il ya eu multiples mesures
notamment le transfert essentiellement
le transfert de la baisse des charges
sociales et transférés vers la sagesse
qui a reporté sa vers les retraités
notamment qui ont perdu notamment les
retraités aisés mais la logique qui
consistait à dire pour lequel à emmanuel
macron avait été élu qui consiste à dire
le pouvoir d'achat il doit d'abord
procéder de l'activité économique et pas
forcément des pouvoirs publics hors
distribution près sur les plus pauvres
bien évidemment a été tenue c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a été acté que ce sont
ceux qui travaillent qui vont avoir un
pouvoir d'achat qui augmentent le plus
et ça c'est cohérent avec la politique
des manuels manqueront donc et
l'institut des politiques de lutte ne le
remet pas en cause ce que remet en cause
institut des politiques publiques c'est
quand on va dans la finesse des déciles
ils vont même vers les services il sait
quand on sait les dix ans les couples à
la société 600 personnes % les plus
riches des pauvres ils sont allés sur
les 1 % voire les 5 % les plus pauvres
les 1% les plus riches on tombe dans des
situations qui sont statistiquement
compliqué
à être évalué c'est ce qu'on appelle un
senti là les sont ils d'accord et alors
pourquoi c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
parce que vous tombez sur des sur des
bases statistiques qui sont relativement
faibles avec des populations très
hétérogène la négociation si j'entrais
hétérogènes ça va de deux camps
dirais-je de salariés qui travaillent à
temps partiel on parle en passant par
des indépendants en passant par des
étudiants qui ont un travail mais qui
ont un travail à temps partiel donc des
situations qui sont extrêmement
compliquées pour lequel une politique
publique peut avoir des effets
totalement contradictoire en fonction de
l'appartenance donc tous ne vont pas
bénéficier de l'apl tous n'ont pas
baissé l'idée même d'aimer prenons un
exemple très concret en 2022 lève sur le
chèque énergie je ne reviens pas sur
fallait-il met 100 euros de cette
manière là ou pas c'est pas mon sujet
mais le sujet est que on sait bien que
sur ces populations là le pouvoir
d'achat va augmenter 3% contre
0 3% pour les 1% les plus riches gens
qu'on voit bien qu'une petite variation
sur les aides sociales sur cette frange
de population la plus concernée a un
effet démultiplicateur très fort et donc
statistiquement c'est compliqué à
évaluer et l'institut d'ailleurs des
politiques publiques appelle lui même à
la prudence sur les conclusions qu'il
faut en tirer sur la précision que l'on
apporte sur c'est sur ces considérations
là d'accord et notamment donc vous dites
sur les 1 % mais plus pauvres on est
bien là sur les 3% ou les cinq pour cent
des 5 % les plus pauvres de gens qui
gagnent si les ménages qui gagnent moins
de 800 euros par ça et qui ont vu quand
même 0 5% pour un ménage qui est à 800
euros par mois partant c'est énorme et
par ailleurs on voit très bien que j'aie
1% sont les privilégiés sont ceux qui
vont gagner le plus en parle de gens qui
gagnent plus de 120000 euros par an et
là-dessus les 0,1 pour cent sont ceux
qui vont bénéficier le plus des mesures
gouvernementales qui ont été mises en
place et c'est là où le bât blesse c'est
là où ça va pas parce que caen met en
place des politiques sociales des
politiques fiscales les politiques
fiscales d'ailleurs sont des politiques
sociales s'est pas fait uniquement pour
abonder le budget de l'état c'est fait
aussi pour gommer les inégalités qui
constituent des problèmes sociaux et
démocratiques quant à des milliardaires
qui par exemple ont des médias etc on se
rend compte que l'affluence que ça peut
avoir donc en gros on voit très bien
qu'on a une politique qui favorise les
très riches et par contre qui n'est pas
bonne pour les très pauvres ça c'est pas
possible c'est pas un épiphénomène
c'est pas un détail c'est qu'il ya un
vrai sujet il faut être en capacité de
mettre en place les politiques qui font
du bien pour les plus pauvres on peut
pas se permettre peut pas de pénaliser
des gens ce qu'ils gagnent pas vrai
qu'ils gagnent moins de 800 euros par
mois est d'autant quand il met ses
factures ils m'ont fait mal parce que
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le rapporte
il le dit mais non sans le rapport dit
pas jusqu'en le rapport ne dit pas du
tout ça on parle effectivement d'un
biais statistique qui est qui est très
important lié à la dire mais le rapport
évoque je venais juste un exemple il
évoque le fait que sur ces 3 % les plus
pauvres ce qui créait la baisse de
pouvoir d'achat de 0 5% c'est notamment
une différence d'appréciation sur
l'impact de la taxe sur le tabac bercy
avait pris avait pris comme parti pris
qu'une taxe pour le sur le tabac va
permettre d'avoir moins de fumeurs et
ses hypothèses étaient supérieures à ce
qu'elles capri l'institut des politiques
publiques donc forcément quand vous
considérez que les gens continuent à
fumer avec une taxe qui s'est élevé à
mécaniquement les revenus baissent or si
on n'avait pas si on avait pris les
mêmes hypothèses leurs revenus ne sont
n'aurait pas baissé donc c'est un effet
statistique qui correspond à des
hypothèses et c'est pour ça encore une
fois c'est pas manquer le rapport
lui-même dit qu'il faut prendre des
précautions et sur les conclusions à la
fin est notre affaire des postures
idéologiques
d'accord avec vous regardant les fédérés
sont pas dans l'idéologie est l'institut
des politiques publiques justement dit
que quand méme août beaux tops
boudabbous bardon les réformes du
gouvernement les apl la taxation sur
l'énergie etc etc qui sont prévisibles
sur sur le pouvoir la junte a déménagé
sur ce que ça va faire aux plus pauvres
notamment l'un tout ça ça engendre des
inégalités et une aggravation pour le
coup des inégalités après on se retrouve
dans une situation où on a des
inégalités qui vont de 1 130 des fois au
moins 1 300 je vous rappelle que ford
henry ford n'en était pas communiste
elles vont faire les jeux montrés moins
parler qui parlait j'ai fini en une
phrase merci beaucoup et laisser parler
qui parlait de différence pour le coût
salarial qui devait aller de 1 40 et si
vous voulez qu'on parle du patrimoine on
a un problème de concentration de
patrimoine par ailleurs alors on a une
relativement
j'ai la population qui détient une
grande partie du patrimoine portant sur
la question de les peindre je finis là
dessus ce conte épargné pendant la crise
ce sont les plus riches ceux qui ont des
épargnes et pendant la crise ce sont les
plus pauvres est en ce moment l'argent
de l'état les produits utilisés c'est du
transfert entre riches ont juste qu'on
s'achète des biens entre nous voilà tout
simplement donc il ya un vrai vrai vrai
sujet on a entendu leurs arguments on
reviendra sur la question du patrimoine
qui est important de jours et revenir
parce que finalement vous n'avez pas
débattu sur la question de la valeur
travail et on peut écouter le ministre
de l'économie bruno le maire il était
ici au sénat devant la commission des
affaires sociales c'était le 17 novembre
dernier sous le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy les français ont perdu en
moyenne 15 euros par an de revenus
sous le quinquennat de françois hollande
ils ont gagné 75 euros de plus par an de
revenus sous le quinquennat de emmanuel
macron ils ont gagné en moyenne 3 196
euros de plus par an de revenus mais ce
rapport établit une chose et le dis de
manière très objective les gagnants du
quinquennat du maine macron ce sont les
françaises et des français qui
travaillent et bien c'était la promesse
initiale de cette majorité et du
président de la république faire en
sorte que ceux qui travaillent vivent
mieux de leur travail la promesse a été
tenue alors sur cette question on va
confronter les arguments de raphaël
legendre et de vincent drezet l'a fait
le jean est ce que pour vous c'est sur
cette valeur travail qu'il faut juger le
finalement le bilan du quinquennat mâcon
en tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
c'est par le travail qu'on en chine hong
kong en enrichir à part dont les
français est certainement pas marre des
aides sociales
d'un état qui sera en l'état à hauteur
de 3000 milliards d'euros à la fin 2022
c'est évident que pour sortir les gens
de la pauvreté pour les émanciper il
faut que ça passe par le travail c'est
la première des manuels maquereau en
2017 on en est à 827 mille emplois créés
depuis le début du quinquennat c'est
bien il faut que ça continue on a encore
trois millions et demi de chômeurs en
catégorie à c'est trop mais ça
s'améliore et c'est bien par la
croissance et par aussi les mesures qui
ont été mis en place à la fois sukaka la
hollande on avait commencé à améliorer
les le marché du travail et puis qui a
continué finalement c'est une
continuation le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron et qui permet d'avoir aujourd'hui
une croissance très belle en robe ou en
sortie crise encore une fois ça ne
durera pas une croissance qui s'améliore
un peu et on ne dira jamais assez c'est
bizien par le travail que les français
pourront s'enrichir certainement pas
parler d'un vincent drezet ce que est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vous
nous dire à fait le genre est ce que
vous
le meilleur moyen pour enrichir les
français c'est pas de retrouver le
travail à des chiffres de retour à
l'emploi qui sont positifs on peut aussi
s'en satisfaire depuis quelques mois
alors sur les chu pôle emploi il faut
aussi de relativiser et tout le problème
effectivement les statistiques mais
lorsqu'on regarde et les catégories à b
et c le total des catégories a b c est
aujourd'hui supérieur à ce qu'il est en
2017 et khalid et pour le coup cette
équipe ce sont les sud de colomb toi il
ya effectivement toute une discussion
tout la catégorie a mais sur les 30 ans
de la catégorie a augmenté d'environ 300
mille personnes après j'étais bien il ya
quand même deux choses sur l'aspect
citiez du rafale de joindre nos jours ce
qui permet aux gens de revenir sur
l'emploi alors que l'activité n'a jamais
été aussi élevé depuis la tendance
plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour pezens
des avis sans faire de politique sert
donc le plateau je suis pas sur le
plateau donc c'est un peu plus compliqué
pour moi donc et de sujets que je
souhaitais aborder ce la question du
travail une des choses dont le maire a
vanté l'action du gouvernement l'une des
choses qui a joué sur la question des
pouvoirs d'achat c'est l'augmentation de
la prime d'activité la prime d'activité
de l'est plutôt réservé à des gens qui
gagnent eux et c'est la redistribution
sociale elle est financée par les
prélèvements obligatoires que soit par
ailleurs veulent baisser donc c'est le
premier sujet c'est pas simplement par
l'ordre by qu'il viendrait des revenus
pérennes et à des augmentations de
salaires réseau améliorer la réactivité
c'est parce qu'il ya une augmentation de
l'activité parce qu'il a fallu faire non
de donner des gestes suite au monde et
gilet jaune par ailleurs on peut revenir
sur la question les revenus la détention
du patrimoine les premiers gestes du
gouvernement en place est quand même
assez factuel genre mais également sur
les données de l'insee sur le banc très
social les premières mesures ont
consisté à alléger la fiscalité des
revenus du patrimoine avec un
prélèvement forfaitaire unique c'est à
dire l'impôt proportionnel c'est le
revenu financier des plus values
financières puis à l'opposé des actifs
financiers ça les rend claire supprimer
l'isf pour trop pour le transformer en
hi-fi parce qu on y reviendra très parts
dans deux interviews je sais que c'est
plus difficile quand on est pas sur le
plateau mais on y reviendra après sur la
question du patrimoine et je vous
donnerai c'est promis
oui mais je voudrais qu'on fasse un
focus sur le lac estion de effectivement
les ménages les plus modestes je redonne
ce chiffre que vous donniez tout à
l'heure où la lux 5 % de ménages les
plus modestes revenus de moins de 800
euros par mois qui ont perdu jusqu'à 0,5
pour cent de pouvoir d'achat et
j'appelle quant à calmer a à nous
rejoindre sur sur ce plateau parce que
quand tu as le sénat à travailler entre
plusieurs mois entre janvier et
septembre sur cette évaluation mais
l'évolution de la paupérisation
exactement je sais pas si cette étude-là
permettent de trancher le débat que vous
avez en face de vous écouter et ça
apporte peut-être juste un nouvel
éclairage aux débats mais effectivement
ce rapport sénatorial a posé un premier
constat a priori c'est que le taux de
pauvreté en france il est ravi d'être
relativement stable depuis dix ans il
s'établit à 14,8 pour sa population avec
9,3 millions de français qui vivent à
effectivement 60% du niveau de vie
médian salle taux de pauvreté va dire à
1015 euros par mois pour une personne
vivant seule mais alors dans leur
rapport les sénateurs note que ce
chiffre est en trompe l'oeil selon eux
la pauvreté monétaire ne mesure pas
assez finement la pauvreté quand on
regarde plus précisément la façon dont
les personnes précaires traverse les
crises eh bien on se rend compte qu'il
est bien un phénomène de paupérisation
en france depuis 2008 on observe une
dépendance des pauvres au système de
redistribution notent les sénateurs
des dépenses contraintes très fortes
notamment en matière de logement ainsi
depuis 2008 depuis cette date le nombre
de bénéficiaires des minima sociaux a
augmenté de 30% pour corse concernée
maintenant 4 25 millions de personnes en
2010 9 notre les sénateurs dans sera
partial on peut dire quoi du constat
depuis l'élection de d'emmanuel macron
alors déjà les sénateurs explique que
c'est compliqué parce que il faut
toujours avoir deux ans d'écart avec un
indicateur pour pouvoir le voir se
matérialiser dans la situation
économique du pays donc ils ont toujours
deux ans de retard pour analyser mais le
rapport note cependant cette statistique
est que vous avez déjà évoqué sur ce
plateau en 2010 9 19% des français c'est
percevait comme pauvres contre 13% en
2010 est je crois que c'est ici que vous
l'avez évoqué il ya des éléments sur
lesquels le rapport est sévère quand
même sur le casier il note qu'il ya des
problèmes par exemple le logement et des
zones de forte tension en france avec du
logement social inaccessible une demande
sur 9 par exemple n'est pas satisfaite
en ile-de-france notre sans rapport et
le logement privé et lui inabordable or
dit le rapport la politique menée depuis
2007 a eu tendance à accroître les
difficultés et provoqué une chute de la
construction note dont toujours ce
rapport la baisse des appels et celle
des moyens des bailleurs sociaux
représentait 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies depuis des milliers cet
essai souvent au détriment des plus
fragiles notent les sénateurs merci
beaucoup merci quand un pur pour toutes
ces précisions si on rentre un peu dans
le
dans l'ordre des propositions maintenant
hors laluque que faire que faire pour
justement ces français les plus modestes
dont on paie je crois qui est un point
sur lequel en fait on a pas de désaccord
peut-être malgré tout c'est le fait que
c'est le travail et se fait d'avoir un
emploi qui permet de protéger mais pas
n'importe lequel et c'est peut-être là
qu'on a un désaccord parce que peut être
certains enfants une valeur morale de
l'emploi on travaille généralement pour
pouvoir vivre nous on peut peut-être
avoir aussi la voir là la chance de
faire des métiers qui ressemble à notre
passion c'est pas le cas pour tout le
monde donc on travaille pour vivre
globalement ce qui protège le plus c'est
un emploi à plein temps en cdi voilà
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à maximiser ce type d'emploi et à
faire attention à la précarisation de
l'emploi ça veut dire aussi qu'on peut
commencer par des choses très très
simple l'état déjà peut donner l'exemple
il peut mieux payer ses fonctionnaires
il ya beaucoup de recours une
multiplication des cdd dans la fonction
publique par exemple une précarisation
de l'emploi etc ça typiquement il faut
que ça cesse surtout à un moment où on a
besoin d'avoir un hôpital public fort
d'avoir un système éducatif et de
recherche fort déjà on commence par ça
ensuite on peut relever le smic et déjà
faire appliquer le smic il faut savoir
que la revalorisation du smic a eu lieu
ces derniers temps n'est pas appliquée
dans un très grand nombre de branches
aujourd'hui parce que il ya la crise qu
vide qui est passée par là et ses excès
du mal à s'appliquer donc il faut
absolument faire en sorte qu'en fait on
puisse augmenter les salaires c'est ça
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui augmenter
les salaires d'un porto un premier temps
et deuxième temps changent et aussi le
rapport de force parce qu'on a besoin
d'un rapport de force plus fort des
travailleurs vis-à-vis les entreprises à
mon sens et ça ça passe par des
syndicats on a un taux de
syndicalisation extrêmement faible un
dialogue social très problématique
d'autres pays donc ça faut absolument
qu'on change at pourquoi pas aussi une
garantie de l'emploi pour les plus
jeunes dans le domaine de la transition
écologique par exemple c'est des choses
qu'on peut mettre en débat mathieu c'est
quand même si on est là dans l'heure de
l'analyse la réponse politique le
pouvoir d'achat c'est un thème piège
pour l'exécutif oui toujours toujours et
on voit bien c'est un sujet passionnant
de débats d'experts de chiffres c'est un
débat aussi réelle entre entre les
politiques surtout en pleine campagne
électorale mais il est souvent décorrélé
de la perception des français on l'a vu
la meilleure preuve c'est quand vous
êtes au pouvoir et que vous êtes obligé
de dire aux jambes ainsi le pouvoir
d'achat augmenter c'est bien écrit un
problème c'est là qu'ils sont pas rendu
compte que je me fais de l'affiché ouais
mais par ailleurs quand on donne un
chiffre ga c'est un indicateur qui ne
parlent à personne indicateurs du
pouvoir d'achat en dehors des morts de
mercy personne ne comprend rien des gens
regardent juste ce qui est dans le cadre
des phases que dans notre fonds chariots
de supermarché pardon et donc ça nasa ne
ça n'a pas de sens de leur dire ça
augmenté de + 4 % ben oui ça leur fait
une belle jambe alors c'est toujours
très compliqué sauf peut-être quand on
atteint des montants records 1 j'ai
retrouvé quand son 1962 avait progressé
de +10 et demi pour cent le pouvoir
d'achat en un an pas assez c'est
colossal selon l'insee mais l'inflation
à l'époque c'est sa réputation et
ensuite il faut le rappeler de toute
façon politique est une règle d'airain
qui paye creed mais c'est que le pouvoir
est toujours blâmer pour ce qu'il prend
et les jamais gratifié pour ce qui le
rend donc en clair vous pouvez baisser
les impôts les lecteurs considéra au
mieux que c'est normal au pire il
oubliera dans l' inverse si vous
augmentez il ne se souviendra que de ça
et ce même si vous tenté par la suite de
les baisser c'est ce qu'a fait tenté
d'en se souvient françois hollande à la
fin de son quinquennat est donc ya pas
défaits dans les urnes si juste un effet
négatif si le pouvoir d'achat baisse il
ya souvent sanctions mais s'il augmente
ça vous empêche pas de perdre regardez
dans les années 80 le pouvoir d'achat il
s'était effondré jusqu'à -2 23% en 84
jacques chirac le fit remonter à 3,989
battu sous lionel jospin dans les années
90 la france le créa jamais autant
d'emplois en si peu de temps le pouvoir
d'achat augmente à tout au long de son
mandat éliminer des premiers tours donc
on voit bien pourquoi les adversaires
des manuels macron tente d'appuyer là où
ça fait mal sinon sur les chiffres en
tout cas sur la perception essayons vaut
bien pourquoi du coup ça devient un
thème de campagne évident effectivement
je vous entends de là dessus eric
delannoy sur la halle la l'utilisation
par les politiques finalement des
chiffres que vous maniez les uns et les
autres alors c'est à dire un feu d'abord
un on leur fait dire ce qu'on veut et 2c
enfin pardon je vais être extrêmement
sévères mais les politiques sont très
fainéants pour imaginer des des mesures
qui seraient des mesures structurelles
plutôt que continuer à distribuer enfin
moi j'entends quand j'entends les
propositions qu'on vient d'entendre là
on est sur un logiciel classique de en
gros faut consolider les acquis quoi va
faire un rapport de force alors que
beaucoup d'entreprises comme la mienne
on essaie de mettre en place des
rapports de coopération avec les
salariés rapport de force va falloir
qu'un jour on n'en sortent quand même un
la lutte des classes sur ces sujets là
c'est un peu dépassé donc aux consoles
il consolide et akli mai mais c'est un
peu c'est un peu le problème c'est que
mais en revanche on parle de formation
tout au long de la vie par exemple enfin
moi je l'entends pas enfin on a dit que
le travail c'est ce qui permet le mieux
de l'augmenter les d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat
commençons par consolider ce qui est en
train d'être faits sur l'apprentissage
on a des records d'avant sial j'entends
personne dire de satisfecit là dessus on
est en train d'arriver au niveau de
l'allemagne ce qui est quand même
considérable on a doublé le nombre
d'apprentis en disant en peine pour dix
ans en trois ans l'apprentissage c'est
le meilleur accès à l'emploi aujourd'hui
on le sait tous les pays du nord nous
l'ont montré le taux d'emploi
effectivement heureux augmente donc on
est sur une formation tout on avis je
sors du sommet de l'inclusion économique
aujourd'hui c'est un somistes mai à
bercy qui consiste à faire en sorte de
mobiliser les entreprises pour faire en
sorte de d'accroître le taux d'emploi en
recueillant et en formant de manière
spécifique des jeunes qui sont laissés
sur le bord du chemin j'en entends pas
parler ça on revient sur consolidé est
là qui gérait des rapports de force mais
non il va falloir qu'on invente des
formes de coopération qu'on fasse en
sorte d'inclure des gens pour
reconnaître que notamment la diversité
en entreprise ça crée de la valeur parce
qu'il faut parler de créer de la valeur
il faut pas parler d'en détruire donc
pour ça il faut qu'on donne le plus
d'informations possibles tout au long de
la vie et ça j'aimerais bien avoir un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle qui
nous parle de son programme sur c'est
quoi la formation tout au long de la vie
je ne l'entend jamais est-ce que ça
s'adresse à vous un camp est mort là luc
danjou la parole est ce que votre
logiciel est dépassée si si j'entends
eric delannoy et puis ensuite je
donnerai la parole dans la foulée va 100
ça
je sais même pas quoi dire quand on a un
président des etats-unis qui en en
parlant de la france le maire il ya des
entreprises en lice et je vous souhaite
former une vraie idée vous aussi dont
voir et je ne parle pas moi j'ai rien
contre les entreprises je suis pas du
tout en train de faire une opposition
stérile entre public et privé ça
n'existe pas l'opposition entre public
et privé d'ailleurs y'a pas de priver
son public ça n'existe pas donc tout ça
est entremêlé profondément je suis par
contre pour arrêter d'être naïf à un
moment on se retrouve dans une situation
où on a une politique de l'offre depuis
des années depuis des années on est en
train de renier sur une partie notre
modèle social pour donner un certain
type davantage à certains types
d'entreprises cice crédit impôt
recherche etc etc et ça n'a pas créé les
emplois attendus ça on peut peut-être le
reconnaître non from the run est parce
que toutes les études le pauvre pour le
coup non un problème d'investissement
public demain au niveau français pour la
nutrition toujours le même problème
d'investissement j'aimerais qu'il chante
j'aime enseigner les bonnes politiques
peut-être que ça changerait je trouve
qu'il n'a jamais été aussi
problème d'investissement public au
niveau français au niveau européen on
avait besoin massif d'investissements
publics pendez-les toujours excuse moi
en fait quand vous parlez je vous écoute
pas
j'aimerais revenir au mans aussi métrage
sais je verrai ton des choses comme ça
que j'aimerais pouvoir moi aussi finir
mes phrases tranquillement merci bull
c'est ça aussi le respect donc on est
dans un moment où on a besoin d'argent
pour pouvoir faire de l'investissement
public met en place sa transition
écologique qui permettra justement de
créer des emplois et pour ça on a besoin
aussi une fiscalité juste et c'est on
voit bien qu'il ya un sujet
d'accroissement des inégalités et on
voit bien aussi qu'un problème de
paupérisation on se retrouve pas dans
une situation où il ya des gens qui
travaillent et qui font qu'ils passent
leurs nuits sont des rangs points sans
qui un sujet aujourd'hui de pouvoir
vivre décemment je suis désolé je suis
toujours surpris d'entendre parler
libéralisme dans le pays le plus taxé au
monde et on a le taux de dépenses
publiques le plus élevé au monde 60 % la
dépense geek
l'équivalent du pin ou de la régression
c'est également l'un des pays où les
plus gros distributeur au monde mais
bien sûr médiation c'est pour ça que les
inégalités ne bouge pas et sont assez
faibles il faut se rendre compte que
peut-être que le problème du pouvoir
d'achat en france et ça a été le cas de
2011 à 2014 c'est le point de l'étain la
moitié de ce que verse votre employeur
par
dans les pas et les caisses de la
sécurité sociale
peut-être qu'en réduisant un peu en tout
cas en améliorant parce que réduisent on
y arrivera certainement jamais mais en
travaillant sur l'efficacité de leurs au
public dépensé on pourra faire en sorte
d' alléger les charges sur les salaires
faut que ça aille dans la poche des
travailleurs plutôt que
jamais le mot de libéralisme estime qu'
on n'est pas dans un état libéral
néo libérale au mais sûrement pas dans
un état libéral j'ai promis à ma santé
je vais redonner la parole donc je le
fais maintenant la théorie du
ruissellement on peut aussi dire ça
comme ça est ce que vous y croyez ou
au bac le côté monsieur comme joe biden
qui est un pragmatique il a dit que ça
n'avait jamais marché c'était
intéressant de demander un bush le
président américain ce qui est
intéressant 24 pensent et ce quel que
soit le qualificatif qu'on donne
politique ni démêler le ccn mi temps
c'est un fait que notamment 2010 elle
avait quand même une réunion des
politiques et le ca s'est traduit
notamment par des choix breaking
annoncée par la compagnie andres nous
allons laisser toute la côte russe
s'était nous allons baisser réellement
inscrits il faut fédérer ni nom ni son
héroïne financiers et les plus-values en
cas d'effet pervers le monstre plus
values à court terme et il fit nous
allons transformer lisf en oeuvre sur la
fortune immobilier à l'idée c'était quoi
c'était de venir en aide aux démarches
des valeurs au curry s'ils vont à
vérifier ça d'après la croissance et
l'envoie si nous ramener volvo il ya 50
ans aime je me disais les profits
d'aujourd'hui et de demain les emplois
d'après demain le bilan qui a été dressé
l'instant ce stratégie pardon à matignon
est quand même assez clair effectivement
le bénéfice de cette très grosse entrée
sur les 1 2 % des français les plus
riches le sénat a dit également et en
termes d'investissements crâne en attend
toujours voilà je fais mais c'est
vraiment le constat le français tratégie
ce qui est d'ailleurs assez étonnant
c'est que même revelli en frac bio et on
verra ensuite le bilan est fait on
arrivait ensuite ça s'est effectivement
ajouté au reste si peu en 2018 et la
même taxe intérieure sur la consommation
de produits énergétiques
dans un contexte très contraint alors
qu'on veut celui ci en tout cas il était
très concrètement par le macis à ceux
qui qui l'ont légumes sauf à générer les
jones qui a ensuite amené des mesures
n'étaient pas une qui nous plaît mais
dictée indemnisation et sait comment
améliorer les bilans gains distribution
vision des choses et c'est
maintenant c'est la redistribution
cedaro distribution qui est permise par
les pros les mangas thouars et un
dernier mot sur les problèmes en
guettant rugby toujours que il ya eu des
efforts massifs en termes de gestion
publique ont fêté les 20 ans des
allemands venus
était resté immobile il pour autant et
pas oublier que plus de la moitié des
ces prélèvements c'est la sécurité
sociale donc si on est mairesse il
faudra dire ce qu'est ce qu'on bâtisse
c'est aussi un débat nous associe déjà
merci merci d'être intervenu merci
vincent drezet vous ça vous et réagir
vous voyez on aura juste d'un mot pour
préciser que alors effectivement le
dernier rapport de francs stratégie
indiqué qu'on voyait pas
directement les fonds les deux milliards
et demi de suppression isf dans
l'investissement pour l'instant un tout
petit peu de recul on n'a que deux ans
sur la mesure 2001 est une année
extrêmement compliqué et surtout rappelé
que la réforme de la fiscalité du
capital et la baisse de l'impôt des
sociétés nous a simplement fait place
pas passer d'une place un peu exubérante
et hors norme en europe un retour vers
la moyenne de ce que pratiquent tous les
pays européens tout l'idée simplement de
revenir un peu dans le rang pour être
compétitif et bat le résultat c'est
peut-être que la france est aujourd'hui
le pays le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers en europe on
peut dire merci au breakbeat londres a
été très longtemps numéro un mais il se
trouve qu'en revenant dans la moyenne
européenne
effectivement vous avez des
investisseurs étrangers qui regardent
peut-être davantage
quand est ce qu'ils font quand est-ce
qu'ils vont s'installer en france et la
france a toujours attiré les
investissements bien sûr on était numéro
trois pendant très longtemps on avait
une juge assez mauvaise image sous
françois hollande aurait été d'un été
riche et les investisseurs étrangers des
75 35 la fois à 75 % plus cher mais
c'est si je peux répondre également est
le pays des 35 heures on est aujourd'hui
le pays le plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers en europe
allez ça aussi c'est plus qu'une bonne
place il est et des débats
non
juste sur les investissements directs à
l'étranger on a toujours été dans le top
3 et pourquoi parce qu'on a une main
d'oeuvre extrêmement fort mais très
compétitif et on a des bons services
publics le joueur fera structure c'est
notamment ce que disent d'ailleurs tous
les investisseurs extérieurs c'est qu'on
sait qu'en france on bénéficie justement
de bons services publics que les gens
une couverture santé et une retraite et
c'est d'ailleurs une des critiques qui
étaient faites aux états unis par par
certains types d'investisseurs qu'ils
aient on avait eu si peu chez vous
pourquoi parce qu'en fait vous avez pas
un bon système de retraite on doit
prendre parti en doit payer les
retraites des salariés donc
problématique de vouvoyer d'avoir un
état providence c'est être compétitif
qui en plus à une fiscalité à peu près
normale par habitant termine là dessus
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat merci à tous les 5 merci
mathieu